[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en España
con elecciones adelantadas por el
presidente socialista Pedro Sánchez para
el próximo 23 de Julio lo analizamos en
esta mesa con benua peli docente
historiador e hispanista bienvenido
Gracias Mercedes doctor en historia y en
estudios hispánicos docente en la
universidad de París 8 bienvenida
Mercedes Buenos días Carlos
especialista de España bienvenido
elecciones en España de alto voltaje hoy
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
la derecha española encabeza los sondeos
para ganar las elecciones del próximo 23
de Julio adelantadas por el presidente
socialista Pedro Sánchez después de los
malos resultados que obtuvo partido en
las municipales y autonómicas del pasado
mes de mayo falta saber ahora Qué
impacto van a tener los pactos
regionales de la derecha con la extrema
derecha de vox de Cara a unas generales
en las que se enfrentan básicamente dos
bloques una un bloque progresista
liderado por el propio Sánchez junto a
la nueva izquierda de suministra de
trabajo Yolanda Díaz y un conservador
liderado por Alberto Núñez feijó que muy
probablemente supondría la entrada de la
ultraderecha algunos ministerios con un
partido vox que supone para muchos una
amenaza a derechos sociales adquiridos
muy importantes en España por los
españoles y las españolas y por el
colectivo lgtbi y también por el
movimiento feminista repasemos algunas
portadas ABC vox cae y se pone en riesgo
la mayoría absoluta de la derecha con un
sondeo que otorga al ppdf hijo la
victoria como todos los publicados hasta
ahora por otra parte el país feijó
admite que gobernará con vox si necesita
sus votos el periódico de Cataluña
publicó una entrevista con Sánchez hemos
visto el tráiler de una película tene la
del pacto PP Box bueno Pedro Sánchez ha
jugado para empezar la carta del todo
nada convocando un adelanto electoral
tras el batacazo en las municipales del
pasado mes de mayo entienden la
estrategia del presidente español bennua
ha sido una sorpresa no hay que olvidar
que el lunes 29 de mayo cuando convoca
las elecciones nadie se esperaba este
titular y sobre todo yo creo que lo ha
hecho de una manera
muy arriesgada pero también muy pensada
el problema no es tanto que el partido
socialista haya perdido las elecciones
del 28 de mayo porque ha retrocedido un
poco pero no ha sido un descalabro
importante pero más bien eficiente a
Perú muchísimo poder territorial y el
poder territorial significa también para
un partido pues una buena salud
financiera administrativa y para colocar
a sus militantes Entonces yo creo que la
reacción del presidente Sánchez ha sido
primero cortar cualquier activo de
Rebelión dentro del partido dentro del
partido porque hay que suponer que lo
que ha perdido el partido socialista
perdiendo las municipales y las
autonómicas es muchísimo poder cotidiano
poder de hacer y entonces eso le ha dado
miedo y como sabe que tiene un partido
dividido donde el liderazgo de Sánchez
es muy potente pero también criticado
por algunos ha querido salvarse con
forzando estas elecciones y haciendo que
todo el partido se movilice para entrar
en campaña y lo que vemos hoy en día es
que el partido está movilizado Pero
quizás no esté movilizado al 100% las
dos españas encarnadas en dos bloques
probablemente en dos coaliciones frente
a frente está sumido Mercedes ese
escenario en España que hay un binomio
que va a llegar al poder y que depende
de El de Sánchez Díaz con la nueva
izquierda o el de feijó abascal está
asumido ese choque de bloques muestrario
España es un país con una larga
tradición de bi en realidad lo que lo
que era también nuevo y bastante
excepcional era esa situación en la que
había varios partidos que tenían
posibilidades en coaliciones
evidentemente de llegar al poder y esa
ruptura del bipartidismo a partir sobre
todo de 2011 de la emergencia de nuevas
fuerzas políticas como podemos y
ciudadano ese era en realidad el nuevo
escenario en realidad yo creo que
estamos en estos momentos en la vuelta a
una situación que ha sido en realidad la
clásica de la Democracia española desde
la transición es decir esos dos grandes
partidos con posibilidades reales de
llegar al poder dos grandes partidos de
gobierno y el resto de las fuerzas Están
volviendo a reagrupar en torno a esos
dos polos Entonces no me parece que sea
una situación sorprendente más bien lo
sorprendente era lo contrario y por
volver a lo que decía
Me parece que Efectivamente
es una estrategia interesante que tiene
también que ver con el personaje de
Pedro Sánchez que es un político muy
hábil muy estratega y efectivamente por
un lado se trataba de cortar cualquier
crítica que pudiera venir dentro del
propio partido el psoe es un partido en
el que tiene mucho peso unas figuras que
se conocen comúnmente como los varones
que son líderes territoriales pero yo
creo que también de lo que se trataba
era de romper una estrategia mediática
muy muy agresiva por parte de la derecha
y de la extrema derecha que hubiera
hecho realmente un infierno de esos
meses hasta la próxima convocatoria
electoral y yo creo que la idea era
también cortar esa dinámica Y adelantar
las elecciones era el mejor modo de
hacerlo lo cierto que estos días estamos
visualizando los pactos que la derecha
está teniendo que está teniendo que
hacer con vox a nivel regional con la
ultraderecha parte de la estrategia de
Sánchez imagino también adelantando
estas elecciones será visualizar esos
pactos Hasta qué punto eso funciona
ciril Pues precisamente esto estos
pactos se están forjando ahora y van a
seguir haciéndolo porque según la
comunidad Autónoma de la que se trata
puede durar hasta después del 23j y en
efecto tenemos que recordar que el PP y
Box Solo hasta ahora han gobernado
juntos en la comunidad Autónoma de
Castilla y león mientras que en otros
territorios vox sí que apoyó la
investidura del PP pero sin gobernar
directamente así que en efecto
va
se supone que Sánchez juega esta carta
agitar la bandera ultra de los miedos de
la ultraderecha Y de lo que puede
suponer para derechos adquiridos por los
españoles un país que ha progresado
socialmente y lo reconocerán muchísimo
en los últimos años con leyes muy
innovadoras incluso comparándolo con
países como Francia agitar los miedos
del ultraderecha sigue movilizando en
España os está asumiendo la que vox está
ya en las instituciones de una forma más
o menos no Yo creo que lo que es muy
interesante y lo hemos visto justo
después del 28 de mayo con estos
primeros pactos sobre todo el pacto de
valencia que ha sido una cosa clave para
y vamos a decir lanzar la campaña y la
reacción del partido socialista
denunciando eficiente la alianza entre
el partido popular y vox pero yo creo
que el partido popular está muy
consciente de que en realidad acercarse
demasiado a vox es la garantía de perder
las elecciones el partido popular y esto
era estrategia de Facebook es centrarse
presentarse como una derecha liberal
Europea
moderada y el modelo es claramente el de
juanma Moreno en Andalucía pero también
con la otra pierna que es la pierna al
uso en Madrid estos dos modelos pero
efectivamente hay que poder gobernar en
algunos territorios de ahí el el Los
acuerdos con Box pero yo creo que
justamente
la radicalización del discurso de vox la
brutalidad y la agresividad del discurso
de Santiago abascal por ejemplo o de
Jaime Ortega Smith todo eso perjudica a
la estrategia del partido popular con lo
cual naturalmente el partido socialista
tiene mucho interés y tiene que poner
toda la carne en el asador para hacer
creer que si llega el PP Xbox el que
entra en el gobierno pero yo creo
sinceramente algunos ministerios
los números no dan pero la estrategia
Y se cree que con 150 esqueños podría
gobernar en solitario y está dispuesto
meter las elecciones y vox votaría con
la izquierda Pero sería si ese es el el
escenario el PP arrasa con mayoría
absoluta en la repetición Confía en el
voto útil de la misma forma que a lo
mejor lo puede confiar Sánchez no de
cara al 23j es decir van a son unas
elecciones de mucha llamada al voto útil
sobre todo por la parte de fijo para
para como lo de Mercedes Pues bueno Yo
no lo tengo tan claro como yo creo que
efectivamente sí que hay una cierta
normalización del discurso de extrema
derecha en España del discurso de vox y
una ambigüedad muy grande de los líderes
del PP o sea se ha visto por ejemplo en
el caso de extremadura con María
Guardiola a la que se ha obligado
literalmente a tragarse sus palabras y
pactar con vox cuando había dicho muy
claramente que nunca jamás pactaría con
un partido machista xenófobo etcétera
que claramente tiene además en su en su
programa electoral cuestiones que son
anticonstitucionales como por ejemplo la
toda la cuestión de la organización
territorial porque vox propone una
recentralización quitar competencias a
la autonomías es decir más allá incluso
de temas que puedan parecer más
abstractos como la política migratoria
Bueno más abstractos depende porque
también tiene medidas extremadamente
concretas o más generales pero
efectivamente Bueno hay una dudas
razonables sobre el carácter democrático
de ciertas medidas propuestas por vox o
incluso el carácter constitucional y a
pesar de todo
feijó Núñez espejo no dice claramente
que no va a pactar con vox a nivel
nacional
deja de una manera muy gallega Por
cierto deja planear esa duda sobre Bueno
sí pero no pero no sabemos pero va a
depender entonces bueno efectivamente
esa duda está ahí Y tampoco hay que
olvidar que Santiago Aba no es tampoco
un extraño es alguien que sale de las
filas del PP que efectivamente luego ha
radicalizado extremadamente su discurso
porque era la manera de tener ese Nicho
político de extrema derecha que estaba
más o menos vacío en España pero tampoco
es alguien que sale de ninguna parte Lo
cierto es que los indicadores económicos
españoles están bien que el gobierno
podría sacar partido de ellos pero
parece que no lo hace Parece que la
agenda se lo marcan otros temas civil no
se habla demo se habla poco de economía
excepto Sí en el programa de sumar las
ahora famosas 180 páginas que hablan
mucho la economía y que hablas
la nueva izquierda creada por la
ministra de trabajo y vicepresidenta de
Pedro Sánchez Yolanda Díaz lo digo
porque muchos oyentes
y espectadores no sepan lo que es sumar
absolutamente y es una agrupación que de
hasta 16 partidos y movimientos de
izquierda
podríamos hablar de la de la inflación
que recientemente ha subido de nuevo
porque España no es una excepción en
Europa por ejemplo ahora mismo en torno
a la inflación y podemos hablar también
de la del acceso a la vivienda que sigue
bastante difícil mientras que es uno de
los programas más importantes de la
legislatura actual la de Pedro Sánchez y
de podemos y económicos en realidad Los
indicadores son buenos el gobierno
podría sacar pecho de ello y en cambio
no está el tema en campaña
no sé si todos los ciudadanos están muy
asegurados sobre la economía Mercedes
una último apunte O lo haces la puerta
de la pausa porque nos tenemos que la
pausa que si no me regañan y enseguida
vuelvo con ustedes aquí en Primera Plana
hasta ahora
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar es de mujeres en ellas hoy
hablamos de nuestra diversidad nuestros
logros y nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
iremos en primera plan esta semana
hablando de las elecciones españolas del
próximo 23 de Julio con benua
pelistrandi y docente historiador
hispanista Mercedes yusta doctora en
historia Eli y el investigador y
geógrafo civil trepie bueno España
tiene la mayoría lo comentábamos antes
de ir a la pausa muchos de los
indicadores económicos españoles están
en verde el gobierno podría hacer
campaña podría sacar pecho de ellos
también de la influencia de España en
las instituciones europeas algo que ha
mejorado en los últimos años sin embargo
estos temas no están en campaña estos
temas están desaparecidos Por qué el
gobierno no nos saca pecho de ello Pues
yo creo que hay varias cuestiones con
respecto a esto que efectivamente he
visto desde fuera por los analistas es
un poco misterioso yo creo que
efectivamente Los indicadores
macroeconómicos están en verde pero
quizá no coinciden del todo con la
percepción de una parte importante de la
población y con respecto a esto yo creo
también que
campaña o la en estos momentos la
disputa política En España se juega
mucho más en el campo cultural que en el
campo económico y esto pienso que es en
parte porque justamente la extrema
derecha ha conseguido colocar su agenda
en los medios de comunicación en las
redes sociales y que se hable justamente
de estas cuestiones de orden cultural
que preocupan a la población pues desde
cuestiones relacionadas con la identidad
española que es un tema Pues que en
estos momentos es muy candente todo lo
que tiene que ver con las cuestiones de
lo que la extrema derecha llaman la
ideología de género y el feminismo leyes
que han sido polémicas como la ley trans
la ley del solo si es sí que tienen
aspectos positivos pero de la que de las
que los medios de comunicación digamos
afines o antianchistas por decirlo de
alguna manera
sobre todo comunicado los aspectos más
negativos el gobierno tampoco ha
comunicar desde mi punto de vista
correctamente con respecto a estas
cuestiones y todo esto ha hecho un clima
la vivienda por ejemplo es una cuestión
muy interesante de observar en la cual
efectivamente hay una ley de vivienda
que presenta avances sociales que vistos
desde fuera parecen muy positivos Pero
hay una percepción negativa de esta ley
Por una parte de la población todo el
tema de las ocupaciones y este nuevo
actor que es un actor no sé si llamarlo
para político o cómo llamarlo que es
esta organización que se llama desocupa
con un personaje totalmente siniestro
llamado Dani Estévez que ocupa un
espacio probablemente en las redes mucho
más importante de lo que parece o de lo
que o del peso que realmente puede tener
pero que orienta el debate Entonces yo
creo que estos son cuestiones que son
importantes para tener en cuenta y luego
hay otro factor más que es el factor
Catalán Cataluña que desde fuera de las
fronteras españolas dicen bueno y ha
desaparecido el tema el tema de Cataluña
Claro en este tiempo desde el punto
álgido del pruse es en 2017 han pasado
muchísimas cosas Sánchez anunció hace
justo dos años en junio del 21 la
apertura de un tiempo nuevo para
Cataluña tras el indulto a líderes
independentistas y lo recuerdan también
reformó el delito de sedición claro
Sánchez Confía en que Cataluña leope
como ganador de estas elecciones algo
que muestran los sondeos que el psoe va
a ganar en Cataluña el psg en este caso
pero no sé el cálculo que han tenido
estos últimos pasos en el resto de
España cómo cómo lo interpretan es decir
porque quizá la interpretación y la
visión que se tiene de Cataluña de cómo
se ha calmado el sufre Catalán es muy
distinta en otros partes del territorio
español sí claramente Es verdad que vox
realmente aprovechado la crisis catalana
para reforzar su discurso nacionalista
españolista pero también Creo que quizá
uno de los errores de Pedro Sánchez ha
sido maniobrar siempre de manera oblicua
en vez de decir lo que quería
cuando en el 2019 dice no puedo gobernar
con podemos Porque no podría dormir es
una frase que todos los españoles
recuerdan y del mismo modo cuando nunca
indultaré a los líderes del proceso y lo
hace yo no pongo en duda de que
seguramente políticamente era necesario
esta esta segunda fase pero eficiente
eso vuelve como un boomerán Y entonces
Pedro Sánchez está absolutamente
frágilizado por estos errores de
comunicación pero me llama mucho la
atención por ejemplo que alguien como
feijo esté muy atento también a la
cuestión catalana para no volver a
reabrir una frente que sería realmente
una mala noticia para España y lo que es
muy interesante también es que Facebook
ha sido durante tres años presidente de
la comunidad Autónoma de Galicia y sería
la primera vez si pongo entre paréntesis
aznar que fue presente en García León en
los años 90 pero no era con las mismas
competencias sería la primera vez que
podríamos un presidente de una comunidad
Autónoma dar el Salto hacia un gobierno
central y eso podría ser interesante
desde el punto de vista de la
articulación entre las administraciones
no está hecho pero podría ser
interesante de cosas que Sánchez dijo
que no haría en su momento bandazos que
ha dado también el tema de Marruecos se
lo recuerdan Quizá lo que se le echen
cara al presidente más allá de que cada
uno pueda poner la palabra mentira a
cambio de opinión es que no haya salido
a explicar esos cambios no Por qué
Sánchez porque a día de hoy todavía hay
cosas como lo de Marruecos que no ha
salido a explicarlas
y creo que también sorprendió a su
propio partido y más allá Al conjunto de
la izquierda que ya estaba fragmentada Y
que lo está todavía más ahora y no todo
el mundo Incluso en la izquierda
Comparte el giro a favor de Marruecos en
la cuestión del Sahara occidental
Mercedes Por qué Sánchez quizá hay un
error una vez salido a explicar porque
cambios de opinión se le puede conceder
a todo el mundo no pero no salir a
explicarlos sí que hay una
responsabilidad política en ello no Sí
desde luego y bueno evidentemente Yo no
sé cuál puede ser la razón es lo que sí
es cierto es que
Pedro Sánchez ha dado la impresión
durante toda esta legislatura de ser
prisionero de la coalición con podemos
en cierto modo y muchos de los errores
que se atribuyen a este gobierno pues
probablemente vienen justamente de
disensiones internas dentro del propio
gobierno que no han trascendido a la
opinión pública bueno muchas sí que han
trascendido de hecho los errores el
armazón judicial de la ley del solo sí
es sí es decir ha habido leyes
socialmente muy potentes como la ley
trans o la ley del sí pero a lo mejor
jurídicamente no no estaban con toda el
armamento judicial que deberían estar y
por eso velocidad a la reducción de
penas de gente que ya estaba condenada
no Y eso eso ha pesado mucho ha Pesado
en contra de esta partiendo A lo mejor
de un objetivo bueno de la ley no Sí eso
Esta es una cuestión muy interesante
y efectivamente muy dolorosa muy
dolorosa por ejemplo para el movimiento
feminista que que se ha visto muy
dividido con respecto a esta ley muy
dolorosa evidentemente para el propio
gobierno para la izquierda
es muy difícil saber lo que ha ocurrido
con la tramitación de esta ley Por qué
no se hizo la Por qué no se incluyó la
disposición transitoria que hubiera
evitado que se produjeran estas
reducciones de penas probablemente por
varias razones yo creo que hay que
aludir en este sentido a la campaña
absolutamente
de cualquier interacción sexual porque
si no estamos hablando todo el rato del
solo sí es Sí y Puede que haya Puede que
haya gente que no sepa en realidad es
una es una ley que se llama ley de
garantías de la integridad sexual y que
tiene otras medidas es una ley que de lo
que trata es de garantizar que no sea la
víctima la que tiene constantemente que
probar que ha sido víctima de una
agresión sexual importante al final ha
quedado en nada porque nos hemos fijado
en la chapuza judicial de la poca
cobertura que tenía y además en que no
hubo una responsabilidad de la ministra
de igualdad en el de una dimisión A lo
mejor en ese momento que a lo mejor
hubiera arreglado las cosas pero no
Probablemente lo que quería hacer
alusión también es a la campaña
mediática extremadamente violenta a la
que ha sido sometida Irene Montero como
lo fue anteriormente Pablo Iglesias lo
cual efectivamente no quita pero sí
quita a lo mejor el sentido de la
realidad es decir una persona sometida a
una presión tan fuerte una persona que
además es joven que tiene poca
experiencia política yo creo que eso es
un factor que puede explicar ese
enrocamiento que desde fuera parece
el cable de una persona que se que
realmente se encierra en defender esa
ley contra capa con capa y espada
ha tenido mucho impacto después
justamente en el balance que se puede
hacer del gobierno de Sánchez y creo que
es una cuestión que va más allá del caso
español que es la cuestión de la
socialdemocracia en Europa el gobierno
Sánchez realmente ha rearmado
jurídicamente la socialdemocracia desde
el punto de vista socioeconómico Pero
como los temas culturales se han puesto
por delante y eso Aquí también tiene la
culpa podemos
ocupan todo el espacio y olvidamos que
lo importante de la izquierda es cambiar
las estructuras socioeconómicas porque
cambiando las estructuras
socioeconómicas se permite a la gente
vivir mejor sobre todo en una España que
había sido golpeado por la crisis 2008
de una manera intensísima intensísima y
entonces yo creo que aquí sí un error
político de Pedro Sánchez de confiar
demasiado o casi de dar la parte
política a podemos y él de no poder
asumir una estrategia global y se ha
visto en el en el hecho de que como
presidente del gobierno cuando hacía una
crisis de gobierno solamente afectaba a
los ministros socialistas no tocaba los
ministros le podemos y aquí ha sido un
golpe para Su autoridad y le quita
credibilidad para hacer campaña hoy pero
no sé si del otro lado la contraposición
es vox que que el libre esta guerra
cultural contra lo que ellos denominan
la ideología de género la ideología lgtb
no sé si es la versión española de un
movimiento contra Revolucionario que
afectamos a muchos lugares del mundo
sí probablemente y en efecto
vox puede aparecer coherente para
resistir a una evolución de la sociedad
o sea
el modelo territorial pero también
la evolución de la sociedad española con
la inmigración la evolución de las
relaciones entre hombres y mujeres
la cuestión de la determinación de
género
en todo estos en todos estos temas vox
toma posición con con bastante éxito y
también puedo Añadir con el PP puede
parecer como defensor de la propiedad
socialista hubiera perdido un millón de
votos entre los hombres entre 18 y 54
años
y ahí puede estar una de las claves
ancha de su resiliencia como bueno como
el título de su libro su manual de
resistencia que yo creo que es una
cualidad que incluso sus adversarios le
conceden al presidente Sánchez no que
resiste
[Música]
a lo que sea
volviendo Por cierto a la cuestión que
decías antes que me parece importante de
si vox forma parte de un movimiento más
global
particularidades español con
particularidades efectivamente
sí y por ejemplo una orientación
neoliberal en economía que que no
comparten otros partidos de extrema
derecha esto es interesante Pero
obviamente que vox forma parte de este
movimiento general no hay que olvidar
Que Steve banon va en 2018 a España para
explicarle a vox cómo tiene que hacer y
cómo tiene que manejar las redes
sociales bueno Steve bannon el consejero
de Trump probablemente saben los
telespectadores Y bueno pues han
aplicado esta estrategia con muchísimo
éxito en las elecciones nacionales de
2016 tuvieron 50.000 votos en las
segundas de 2019 casi 4 millones me
quedo sin tiempo para más ha sido un
placer Muchísimas gracias a los tres por
acompañarme hoy a todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana en Primera Plana gracias
[Música]